sculptures en terre cuite en papier ou
encore peinture à l'huile plus d'une
soixante dix oeuvres sont à découvrir au
156e salon de la société versaillaise
departed d'ile-de-france au carré à la
farine à versailles les artistes qui
sont professionnels ont la possibilité
de mettre trois oeuvres et les non
professionnels parce qu'il y en a quand
même qui sont très intéressants ont la
possibilité de mettre une oeuvre nous
avons là dix sept sculpteurs en tout une
soixantaine d'artistes présents ils
viennent uniquement de la région ile de
france comme cet artiste yvelinois ce
qui fait des sculptures en papier
patiner autour du roman d'alice au pays
des merveilles mais aussi autour des
animaux et de l'humain
toutes ces pièces ont une armature comme
une colonne vertébrale c'est un film qui
court le long du corps ensuite je
travaille avec des fils d'aluminium que
je tricote un petit peu tout autour de
la pièce certains sont visibles à votre
oeil
d'autres me serve d'armature autre
invité d'honneur du salon siméon colin
il dessine et an des arbres ou des
éléments comme des branches ou des
feuillages jeu j'adore le serbe n'est
chaîne il ya déjà plus que j'aime moins
parce que nous sortons moins d'actes ce
qui m'intéresse dans les arbres
effectivement la qualité des cavités
entre les broches quand les branches se
découpent bien qu'elle s'était une
certaine lourdeur une certaine amplitude
une certaine une certaine protection en
quelque sorte
24 artistes yvelinois ont participé à
cet événement le salon de la société
versaillaise des artistes d'île de
france est présentée jusqu'au dimanche
21 novembre